قال فيلم أرنو مونين في banankoro من قبل
البطولة التي تلعب فيها
أوا ألفانو إيطاليا موسى ناري بينس
وجدت بين أصدقاء خليج مورو مثل
كن مشرفًا تمامًا
في وديان جان بيلفورت الشهيرة
بالإضافة إلى اصطدام مستوى سيارة بونا
نحن نميل إلى العبث والعربي
طرية في المعدة
[تصفيق]
مصطافنة الرأس
انتل من الحائط ومن خلاله ينتظرني
ليس إذا أكد قانون فالوكس
كان ميشيل دينيت بوش في منزلهم
الوصول إلى فرنسا المصالح ويدير أ
سقف صغير من فن الروك r'n'b الجزائر
عنابة الفارسى المطر مطر ndiaye
انظر هل هي صباح حتى أنا
في الواقع حيث تهيمن المدينة
الذي لدينا في 36
إيزابيل وفرقتها
بلكونة من حيث الداه
صقر كيلر
الفلا الولايات المتحدة هدية مكثفة جدا لواوا
هوس برشلونة
[تصفيق]